There have been very few consequences for
Donald Trump during his presidency for all
of the horrible things he's done.
And by this I mean the bad policies, the ignorant
and ridiculous statements, the embarrassing
actions on the geopolitical stage, the lack
of decorum, the coarsening of the political
discourse, all of it, right?
I mean all of it, all of it.
There have been very few if any consequences.
Now the most immediate and impactful consequences
there could be would be just voting Donald
Trump out in November of 2020 we've heard
from more and more farmers.
I told you about this last week who are clearly
indirectly now saying we are getting crushed
and we know why.
It's because of Donald Trump's tariffs.
This is Donald Trump's fault that our businesses
are imploding and the markets in which we
operate are falling apart.
That being said, I asked the question last
week, will those farmers actually hold Trump
accountable by voting for somebody else next
year?
You can be a lifelong Republican farmer that
is angry at Trump for his tariffs and for
destroying your business, but you might still
be unveiled, unwilling to vote for a Democrat
in November of 2020 we have to wait and see
what voters more broadly are thinking about
Donald Trump and the economy.
May Beau bode well for the left in 2020 or
it may not.
What I mean by that is there's a new poll
from Harvard caps Harris, which is sort of
positive.
A majority of voters say, if we have a recession
in the next year, uh, we will blame Trump
more than anyone else and most people are
worried that indeed there will be a recession
in the next six months.
Now, humans are notoriously bad at predicting
when the next recession is going to be.
Economists included.
We know every day we are one day closer to
the next one because that's how the system
works.
But by and large, we're not good at predicting
exactly when we are going to have a recession.
Sometimes we don't even realize we're in one
until we've been in it for a little bit.
That being said, 57% of Americans would blame
Trump more than the federal reserve or anyone
else.
If the United States were to enter a recession
by the end of the year, 62% of Americans say
they are somewhat or very concerned that there
will be a recession in the next six months.
Remember that Donald Trump has been insisting
that anything bad that happens in the economy
is the Federal Reserve's fault.
Of course, the Federal Reserve is led by the
person that he selected to lead it.
That's rarely mentioned when he talks about
that on tariffs.
63% of Americans believe that the tariffs
are hurting the United States more than China.
74% of Americans believe that it is American
consumers, not China that pays for the tariffs.
Now, that's true.
I'm actually shocked that 74% of Americans
understand this because Donald Trump has done
a good job to the extent that you need to
do a good job to convince ignorant Trumpists,
uh, of saying it's China who pays the tariffs,
even though of course, it is.
Ultimately American consumers passed along
down from American companies and manufacturers
that are paying those tariffs.
So all of this looks great, right?
People understand it's American consumers
paying the tariffs.
People understand Trump is to blame people
understand if we have a recession, Trump would
be more responsible than anybody else.
But then the question is, will the people
blaming Trump for the recession vote for a
Democrat in November of 2020?
And it is the same question that we have about
Republican farmers.
Just because you accurately correctly precisely
blame Donald Trump for tariffs destroying
an economy doesn't mean all of a sudden that
a religious right Midwesterner is going to
go out and vote for a democrat.
So the strategy I've outlined before, there
will be some disaffected Trumpists because
we have a country of 340 million people.
Some disaffected Trump is are going to go
and vote for a democrat.
Great.
We'll take it some disaffected Trumpists are
going to stay home and not vote at all.
That also helps us, assuming that we can get
out our base, but none of this counts as a
strategy.
We must get our base out.
That's it.
As far as the economic stuff, we do actually
have some tools that are disposable to try
to mitigate how bad whenever the upcoming
recession it's coming.
At some point we have tools that we can use
to mitigate the seriousness of the upcoming
recession.
Uh, we can tax the wealthy through increasing
capital gains, through inheritance taxes,
through increasing top income brackets.
We know that that's a tool that can be used.
Is there the political will to do it?
That's a different question.
We can do infrastructure infrastructure spending
to soften a recession to create jobs to improve
communities.
We can look at doing something with student
loan debt and medical debt to free up disposable
income for people to try to push back against
the effects of a recession.
We can deal with the cost of housing and the
rising costs of living to put more disposable
income in people's pockets.
So each of these is a big project that requires
a lot of discussion.
But the point is we now have the 2008 recession
as another case study as in terms of helping
us know what tools that we have at our disposal
can lessen or soften the effect of a recession.
Is Donald Trump willing to use any of those
tools?
It's not clear, but in the meantime we can
say it's good that people will correctly blame
Trump most if we are to have a recession in
the next six to 12 months because that is
where the blame should be.
We actually have specific economic policy
that we can tie to it.
And then the broader question becomes, as
we are now 14 months out from the 2020 election,
will that blame translate not just into saying
you blame Trump, but into actually going to
the ballot box and saying, you know, on some
social issues, I don't agree with these Democrats
or whoever it is that ultimately is the nominee.
But for the good of the economy, I'm going
to vote for a democrat.
That is the big question mark.
And that's what I want to hear from you about.
Will disaffected Trumpists to any significant
degree vote for Democrats, or are they more
likely to just stay home or even vote for
Trump with the caveat that they don't like
everything he's been doing?
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and make sure you're following us on twitch,
twitch.tv/david Pakman, four live streams,
uh, several times per week as well.
[inaudible] hope to see you on one
of them.